okay so I have to bring this up because
like me you're a fan of tattoos which
we've talked about before but there's
one that means a lot to you right
so I'm looking at the sunflowers here
yes
and it's making me think of my mom I
have her sunflower on my shoulder so she
had a sunflower tattoo and I have a
sunflower tattoo I'm on there I have a
sunflower tattoo wait right here
oh that's beautiful
that's really beautiful I love that it's
so funny I have a sunflower tattoo and I
also my mother was against tattoos
um you know kind of religiously like
growing up your body is a temple you're
not supposed to do that oh well and um
20 later my temple it's my design
um so we convinced my sister and I
convinced her to do a tattoo finally
like one year and and she ended up
getting she's the son and I'm the moon
which I have that tattoo in my sister as
a star and we're both inside the Sun so
it's like it's it can be really cool
thing it is my mom had one and I got it
for her birthday oh you know she's
Jewish and Jews don't do tattoos but I
had it for her 65th birthday I think it
was and then unfortunately years later
she had Alzheimer's and I said to my
brother please can you take a picture of
it because I can't remember which
shoulder she had it on on her left or
right shoulder because I wanted the same
tattoo for myself and he tried to take a
picture of her and she's like what are
you doing and so we struggled to get for
like six months and then finally we said
mom we need a picture of your tattoo she
goes what tattoo
but we got a picture on the left
shoulder so I got the same thing and
there we go that's beautiful though to
have her with you I love I love that
[Music]
[Applause]